and if anyone knows of criminals,
please turn themselves in and
turn themselves in to justice because they're going to
find Frank's guys
turn themselves in
[Music] I
was studying and so farmer
this because it was a thousand of water I bought
but
I'm not going  to rest in doing justice
that everyone pays for everything that you help
me the media please
help me do justice with my island
tell me what you want to say I'll put up with it
and the only thing I'm living that
I want justice for me is that  it's not going
to stay like this
I want the father to pay too because
this is a complete and the whole family
they helped they killed me in that house and
I'm sure that the mother of their
sisters that day I went I
experienced something suspicious that day  and I thought
I knew that they were hiding
something and they overtook me in those streets the
san carlos in lapuebla crea there
and that's why I also want to keep the
father too because it's not an accomplice that
someone pay you all  to family because
no one is going to give my son back to anyone
for
them they have to pay they have to
pay for what they did for me
they took my daughter's life and
played her to vote
far away from here in las vegas  I want, I
want justice for my daughter, the only
thing I want is justice, they all pay prisoners
because they are some, they are all
discriminated against, they all win over the
children of all the children, and the father
helped him escape,
I want justice, I am not leaving  to stay
like this until he does justice for me and
I want them to turn themselves in so they don't go
hiding because they're going to find him
he says nothing they're going to find him
leslie was not a bad girl the law was
a very good girl she was studying
she wasn't  she was a student dedicated to
studying and to school the only thing she
did was almost never on the street and I
want justice for thousands and she was a
very good girl I know me
and they didn't have to be that way with me they didn't
have to take her away  ida
I want them to deliver what he
would have and because they will find him in
the center because it is my honor to
see a very good girl I don't know
why he hurt her
because Amazon had no reason to kill them
I ask for justice for me not this  it's going to
stay like this
I want everything in all
hands so that the fear of the
father being collective so that he dies is a
powerful doctor because I, sir, have to
be in Mexico and that you look for them even if
they turn themselves in because they have to pay
they have to pay they don't have to
run away
and don't trust anyone's mothers
I met that boy many
years ago the mother the ex's godmother and no
one and no one lets go of her keep it up for no
reason and with your best friend because look what
it's happening to me you have to
learn what's happening to me
and when you're at the same time I help the
entrance nobody ran there nothing the
neighbors heard when he yelled and nobody
came out to help us
now on Thursday on Thursday I f  ui there
they told me that they were giving
the case as lost since it was already
missing they thought it
was already dead but I kept looking
I was looking for four days outside
of here in Las Vegas looking to see
where else or  except where the guy s was already there
and now that I arrived from there they gave me the
news that he had found her dead and
some clue
not the only thing I knew that it was the same
day as Saturday that same Saturday she
left that I knew the police knew  that they
had gotten angry and that I had left
here
because you are going to say
my sister
told me this that they did a
very good girl and a love
[Music]
I love myself it is justice that he does not
deserve this and they catch his whole
family his father  to all
but very good people
I do not ask for that
[Music]
in this sense there are incidents from me
to me
not
deposit of an American era of born
here not to the parents to prepare a
child dismounts first in water they
endure servi  cio you like me
in 2nd
very well
there are many
yes
and me too
[Music]
like the first one
and
[Music]
no
efe
[Music]
because he took my life because  I
kill him